coverage of e3 2014 you're watching the
Samsung stage I'm very happy to be
joined by andrew Tsubaki from petroglyph
sir you're a lead game designer yeah a
game a lot of RTS fans very much
interested in grey goo and we have a
playable right here is this the first
time you guys have actually had it
playable at e3 oh yeah so this is the
first time we've actually brought to the
e3 e3 show floor to show it off to
everybody to have they get their
impressions you can actually play all
three factions while the beta the humans
and the goo and it's something we can be
really proud to show up and have
everybody take a look at it's not kind
of one of the most important things when
you're talking about real-time strategy
genre specifically is that hands-on time
actually understanding the phone's
micromechanics of what's going on is
like important for hooking people in oh
it's absolutely it's a lot of things we
look forward towards the players to give
us the feedback about how much they're
enjoying a faction are they feeling
where where's the fun that they're
definitely experiencing with because we
really went about creating three very
unique factions and the way they play
the way they interact and how you play
with each of them strategically
especially when you talk about stuff
like the great GU and it's something
that you really haven't seen before in
an RTS it's a bunch of new mechanics
it's combining a race that has no base
building mechanics with two other
factions that do that have very
different base building mechanics and
getting that good asymmetrical gameplay
going awesome what we're looking at the
gameplay right now so please and you
feel free to deep dive on some of this
stuff what are we looking on so yeah
like right now we're kind of looking at
one of the beta basis and the betas are
all about this modularity and
customization and building you know
faces that either really close together
and being very defensive or being very
distributed and building out across the
map everywhere so you can see here you
can see like the the main HQ it's got
two refineries so these income's going
you see two factories and those
factories are defined just turning out
the base units that are available but
right there off to the right you can
even see another factory that's got
another power hub that has both a tech
and a factory on Tatooine and that's
actually creating some specialized unit
that really made that about you that
factory combination very unique into you
into your base as a target and as
something that you're going to want to
protect or you know put out elsewhere so
combining the actual the modular
buildings themselves results in
different tech trees almost exactly the
number of
our hubs the size of the power hub
dictate so you know how what kind of
options you have like that small and
you're only going to get that one tech
attachment there which kind of limit
your options there but it really
distributes the risk you don't have as
many eggs in your basket that you know
if I lose this I'm not losing all my all
my different types of tech units i'm
just usually maybe one specific site
while in the larger power hub
configurations you can get multiple
texts and have a factory that can
produce a lot more cool so in in
competitive realtime strategy games
resource gathering is obviously really
important thing what are the resources
in grey goo and how much of an onus is
on that so we actually went to a single
resource model in grey goo we wanted to
keep everything simple but give it a lot
of depth so we didn't want you to have
to you know really think about okay well
how many resources on my management we
want you to focus on the gameplay of
what is the strategy you're actually
trying to do what units are you playing
with what's the structures you want to
build and really incorporate that
gameplay then really put too much of the
the noodly micromanagement that isn't
always fun so the three different
resourcing mechanics are really kind of
interesting the humans of betas sheryl
loch ewe similarity where they have this
refinery that they place down is any
place this mining extractor out into the
world on a density map of finding the
resource okay and that entire density
map is actually saying hey you know
where can I get the most drain out of it
where can i get my most amount of
resources and how far of a supply line
do I wanted to want to protect well for
the goo that you see there they actually
go around and take bites out of the out
of the world and collect up the
resources and then digest it over time
okay you're really mobile with the goo
you don't actually stay in one place you
kind of come you hit a resource location
you grab the resources and run or
depending on what you want to do with
that you can actually assault a base
assault units and you can see the GU
right there actually kind of make it
push Iran flying with the resources out
there so he's actually kind of a little
bit of an energy shield from that
resource grain itself is to go because
it seemed to have just rolled over a
pretty decent sized squad there so the
goos got its own powers and
disadvantages while it is very very
strong against structures and in units
in a really close combat it's relatively
slow so if you're going to micro you
know you can kite the goo around and
really hit it home to them because for
the goo it's all about the size and you
know they grow for their economics and
then split that off and then create
their units yeah anytime the mother use
taking damage you're actually kind of
hitting the goos economy
so it's that trade-off of like it does
the player want to risk it do they want
to do you know use that and spend the
money to actually do some good real hard
damage or are they going to get guided
around and start really getting their
economy harassed so you don't it's
almost like a push and pull of like do I
really want to be offensive against you
or do I want to really kind of like hold
back and and kind of protect my goo & B
this you know this entity that's running
around the map and you're trying to
chase down and hunt down and and
eventually kill are you in control of
that the scale of each one of those goo
what what you call a unit of goo that's
only your mother do the mother goo &
mother give when you create one like
just obnoxiously large mother goo or it
didn't happen yeah you can so like
you're looking at the screen right now
there's there's three gears that are
actually full-sized they don't actually
get any larger than that okay from there
you can actually take those and combine
them down to make an epic and the epic
is like the map the massive goo it's
just huge monstrosity that's good that
will come over it crushes everything by
just rolling over it it has tentacles
that it burrows into the ground and
comes up and just destroys units from
below it's really that game ending unit
that's gonna break any kind of sort of
stale and because of the scale of them
and I guess the fact that there I don't
think they're permeable you can't other
units can walk through them right yes
they can actually oh they don't do it
the goo race itself is a race of Danites
so you can kind of think of it what is
what would it be like if you had this
huge race of nanites that's just this
big blob that exists in the world that
you're going to have to deal with and
it's kind of like stepping on an anthill
right you have all those answers just
borrowing you up and right now you guys
are actually seeing the the epic being
created so the epic is really did this
big blob of Q that's getting created and
it's eventually going to grow up and
then you can see it right there with the
big three tentacles kind of moving
around and it looks like you were going
to go take this the guy in to start
reading some havoc on the enemy basic an
enemy units walk through it as well then
you're saying they can walk good but
they're going to dissolve as they go
through so right if you have enough
health or you know you might survive it
but in reality you're not going to do
too much so there's a tactical advantage
then to like you know a choke points for
instance like you trying to keeping
players behind it they don't want to try
it if they can't cause that's one of the
benefits of the good and you actually
would use that to its advantage the goo
can actually terrain walk so it doesn't
actually necessarily obey the same
ground movement rules everybody else's
it can climb over mountains
can climb up over cliffs and that
ability lets gives us this great
ambushing type of Billy so there's a lot
of strategies about how do I take this
you know this big blob of goo and then
use it to my advantage you know do i do
i lure you into the bushes and then you
know obviously just jump in there or do
I come out of the forest and just
dissolve you out there without you ever
you know yeah because you could have
with the perspective I guess no matter
wonder what your camera angles out you
could actually hide in one of those
forests and it just pants out and be
correct yeah pretty scary it's a pretty
ominous looking looking feast yeah you
can see there it's playing to it for
another mother as well but yeah there's
one of the cool things about our game
too is it's not we're not angle
restrictive you can actually spam camera
all the way around 360 degrees you're
not locked to some specific actual angle
on the actual game your team has a lot
of a pedigree when it comes to real time
strategy game yeah yes we did we got we
got a lot of guys we have some original
people who made the original team to the
command and conquer we have a few people
who've worked like myself who worked at
relic you've got a lot of knowledge from
there and bringing all that knowledge
together you kind of joke there's almost
a six degrees of Kevin Bacon to RT SS
for at petroglyph you've all taken RTS
we really gotta jump of like one or two
of us to that hey yeah I've worked on
that so we've got a pretty good pedicure
rise of nations you got one there yes we
do actually there's actually worked on
that mne degrees one uh yeah actually I
think it's a one I guess it's a it's
it's a genre where you you either have
you either know it or you don't probably
yeah so that's cool it's great to see
collaboration in there hey we've talked
about two GU can you kind of go into a
bit of detail about what's the
difference between the two egg creature
classes as our war our factions the two
other factions the two other factions
sure so when you look at the spectrum of
players right everybody likes to play a
certain specific way there's people who
like to turtle and and really big big
bill basis there's people who like to be
really really aggressive and there's
people who that pretty much the spectrum
in between the the other two races
actually salt fill in the rest of that
so the goo is that really hyper
aggressive race yes the humans are all
about building the Mesa massive
fortresses so when you look at that base
you can see that there's that big
central power core that everything is
attached to and as you start building
out you can attach different buildings
to try to find a configuration that you
that works for you so you can produce
more units produced offenses drop down
walls and a lot of the stuff that goes
with the human
faction is all about building an almost
tower defense type of fortress that
you're gonna want your enemy to crash
against yeah so they can pulled up walls
that the humans can just move through
without it with impunity and now carry
about they can shoot through them but in
contrast the beta are all about this
they mechanical type structures they
really care more about function than
form and so as a result they're really
there you have really machine powered
units they have a lot of walls that are
like really solid you can actually
configure what type of turrets you put
up on the walls with your own types of
units and you can see some of the units
there for the humans as well so that you
can see there there's the the revolvers
and the Trident which are some of the
base starting units that you got there
and then there's also the artillery unit
and the human are killing it's something
that's very very unique in the way that
it plays if I lit fires exactly a
projectile off that will land it
actually if it misses its target it
actually leaves behind a landmine
they're like this great kind of
combination of use for that you know
whether you say okay I'm going to use
you offensively you're going to be
landing firing into the middle of a very
big you know glob of units getting rid
of that ball of death that might be
coming towards you or you can be mining
your entrances you can be just
automatically telling you to attack
ground and leaving behind a small little
minefield for it to deal with so it
fills a little bit of a dual role it
gets a really a lot of function out of
it we actually have a Tekkit upgrade
system that also goes with the game that
lets you change those roles of some of
those units so right there on screen you
can see one of the Lancers which is this
really big heavy siege unit for the
human and what it starts off is it bores
that laser right into buildings and just
likes to melt it all down but one of the
tech upgrade options you have for it is
to change that laser into being more of
a rail gun shot where you can fire
through like six different units at once
excellent and that kind of changes the
way you would roll and how it fulfills
that role in your army and what you're
going to do so are you guys focusing on
the competitive multiplayer aspect or I
believe when you're releasing this game
you're you're releasing almost the first
section of your single-player campaign
as well we're so we're releasing we're
releasing for everybody we're actually
not trying to ostracize everybody we
wanted to make a great core game so part
of that some of the features are that we
are actually land play you don't have to
have an internet connection alright so
he's not certainly a benefit over
certain competitors yeah so you can
actually go like get on your airplane
flight fly out to Europe and be playing
on with
buddy like right next to you on the
airplane or in the middle of Africa
somewhere on a safari you know wherever
you want to be you know it's hard to get
out there we go oh my god John that
Sports Illustrated shoot it might be
great um one of the other features we
are doing a 15 mission campaign you'll
get to play all three races in that
campaign is that as long as much to do
with trying to educate people about how
the mechanics work as it is actually
forgetting yes it is actually we're the
campaign is going to prep you to play
whatever the game and we really took the
approach that we're balancing this game
so that multiplayer and single-player
you don't have different units you don't
have anything special that's lacking for
you you're playing the same game so when
you go from more single player into
point wanting to play with the skirmish
with the aai you're going to end up
really kind of educating yourself to be
playing multiplayer because when you
walk into multiplayer there isn't a
different type of meta game you've
already been exposed to that meta game
in the campaign and you've been exposed
that meta game in the actual skirmish
battles that you've been playing with
the upon so it's apples for apples when
you transfer over exactly it isn't that
hey there's these special units you'll
never see again we haven't got that much
time left so I want to go in and get
some questions from the community and
Kenneth I'm asked a good question are
there any air units and Konya units
transform into other types of units he
says transformers are awesome so the goo
itself doesn't have any areas yeah one
of the things that are for the race but
the other two factions doing you can
actually see that guy right on screen
each of the Bombers and the fighters are
all have the capability of loading up
and then go hitting of striking
something in the in the world and then
coming back to reload and bring their to
go back at it excellence I when you how
far you guys have from release and are
you doing any sort of beta or early
access that we're doing right now if you
go to Greg ecomme you can actually sign
up for the beta we're in a closed alpha
right now with like friends and family
and stuff so we're opening that up very
very soon here for everyone to get more
fun an interactivity with it we're set
to release this fall and it could be
released on Steam excellence I want to
ask you another question and it is maybe
a ridiculous question but I have to ask
okay realtime strategy genre has always
been associated with sort of very strong
names titles you know command and
conquer rise of nations may be less so
jun warhammer hmm was grey goo like a
working title that you didn't just went
out whatever that that works people like
that one um actually Greg Hugh's got a
lot of a lot of meaning to the game in
itself like rape you refers to the
apocalyptic event of nanites destroying
the world so with the Lord the story of
the game it has a really good close tie
in with that in addition to it there's a
lot of nuances with the name that I'm
hoping I going quite disclosed everybody
ok it's more of a let's see who figures
it out but I'll say the abbreviation for
the name is important and in its own and
it was really something that when we
played this game we had I thing at one
point 250 names up on a wall that we
were like okay which one of this puts
there and we had like we had some of
those strong names and we're like it
still doesn't seem to like fit the
essence of what this game is yeah when
you look at something like that on the
screen and it's it it's this great GU
that's coming to destroy it was like it
is the natural fit for what it is and
I'm bringing the meeting for what the
game is also mad you from petroglyph
thank you so much for coming on the game
7 and showing us great gu yeah so if you
want to get involved in the beta then of
course I go to that website we got a
bunch more stuff coming up here Aramaic
arenas up next we got shadows of Mordor
nosgoth and then codename steam closing
the dead here and my little stint on the
Samsung stage here on gamespot com but
first of all we're gonna check out
what's going on the show floor